well group of teenage girls and Maryland
is fighting back after their male
classmate circulated a list get this
raiding them by their appearance the
Washington Post first reported at the
list was sent around Bethesda Chevy
Chase high school earlier this month the
18 girls who appeared on the list were
rated and ranked based on their looks
Michelle Miller shows us how those girls
well they took matters into their own
hands Michelle good morning they
certainly did good morning we spoke to
six girls senior girls from Bethesda
Chevy Chase and some told us they were
inspired by the me2 movement they say
when they saw the list they felt
objectified and decided it was time to
no longer accept the excuse that boys
will be boys I think that the female
generation is always thinking what did I
do to deserve this and the answer is we
did not do anything
Jane Corcoran says she never wants
another girl to feel the way she did
when she saw her appearance rated on a
list circulated by boys at her high
school in my head you know I tried to
push away the thoughts that you know
come like a number does not define me
and I put a put out a confident front
but it's really hard to think about you
know why is this girl point a point
better than me and Jane was not alone
seventeen other girls appeared on the
list and some told us they also found
themselves questioning their worth when
I saw the list my initial reaction was
just to feel kind of gross so the girls
decided to take action a reason we're
addressing this is because we don't want
it to be normal anymore
they first took their concerns to
administrators but when they reportedly
learned only one male students was being
punished they took it further calling a
meeting the main focus on the meeting
was not to patronize not to point
fingers but it was rather to educate the
girls say more than 70 students showed
up including some of the boys who
created and circulated the list a lot of
girls shared their personal experiences
with the list and how it made them feel
and also experiences with misogyny and
degradation and attempted
objectification and sexual harassment
now the girls are hosting similar coed
meetings
regularly next week they'll have an
event on toxic masculinity and sexual
violence
they've also spoken with younger
students hoping to set a precedent is it
hurtful to see your name on a list with
their classmates with a number text but
of course it's hurtful but I think what
is more like it powerful is what we've
done with our hurt the school principal
told us in a statement she is proud of
the students who work together to move
forward from this incident the
Washington Post spoke to the boy who
first created that list it reports he is
remorseful agrees it is time for a
change and is grateful that the girl
spoke up in fact he was in the meeting
such a mature smart way to handle it to
say we don't want to point fingers we
just want you to know this is for ya
it's important to see how much damage it
can actually I suppose girls have enough
to worry about this yeah and it's not
just in high school so true Michelle